who the hell's permission are you
looking for to do your thing I would not
be an incredibly successful entrepreneur
and neither would he if we hadn't failed
or showed up at a bunch of jobs first
what's up elimination at seven I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so today we're gonna look at should you
quit the job you hate or not and get
perspectives from Gary Vaynerchuk and
Mel Robbins also if you want to know
what Gary Vee and Mel have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you okay
let's kick it off with Gary Vee who says
go do your thing this may be the video
that changes your mindset just a quick
little rant
it's called permission like who the
hell's permission are you looking for -
do your thing like who is this person is
it is it your mom is it society is it
your partner is that the people that are
commenting in your social media is it
something that happened to you when you
were nine
what permission are you looking for I'm
just so tired of you know so many people
are using me right now to give them
permission to do stuff and it is my
literally my literally greatest feeling
of my life the feeling that I through my
content every day on Instagram or my
podcast and giving you permission to win
excites the [ __ ] outta me but my friends
and I can't even like contain it like
very simply like like can you answer
this for me whose permission are you
looking for go do your thing
you're gonna die it's going to end
something bad is gonna happen something
great is gonna happen but most of all
nothing's gonna happen unless you do
something please stop looking for
permission please go do that thing we
wanted to do ask that person out start
that company quit that job you can
always get another [ __ ] job stop
asking for permission make the end of
this year of the moment but you finally
make 2018 a year when you start living
like on the other side is Mel Robbins
who says stick with it you want to know
what to do if you go to a job I hate I
say keep going you're selling cars
you probably hate doing it cuz you want
to be doing something else but what if
you could bring your own style to
selling the cars and you crush it and
you make money and you enjoy it you have
a great time and you put your
personality into it instead of
presenting it and learn what you need to
do every day to show up and do something
that you hate and actually enroll people
and buying cars and then you will
develop the skills that you need in that
are gonna serve you in this business
that you want which is running your own
thing and selling yourself do not put
that job are you crazy I don't carry
Vaynerchuk us telling everyone quit your
job put your job quit them job unless
you have a trust fund or your dad owns a
liquor store I don't think that's a good
idea I think that you should keep it and
develop the discipline to show up there
every day bring your full self to it but
your personality into it crush it in
less time and then take everything that
you're learned
about working with people you can't
stand about selling the people that
don't want to buy something about being
positive in an environment that's really
difficult in setting a goal every month
and freaking crushing it stick with it
for six months a year and then if you've
done it and you've learned everything
you've needed to learn and you've been
hustling on the side building this other
thing you'll have the skills you need to
step into it crush it but do not quit
that job right now all right
I know meets jobs I had that I hated
Chris how many jobs did you have that
you hated ooh I got I had 27 I would not
be an incredibly successful entrepreneur
and neither would he if we hadn't failed
or showed up at a bunch of jobs first
learn on somebody else is done and by
the way if you quit and now you're
strapped for cash you're gonna do a
super job at your social media and
everything else because you're gonna put
all the pressure of earning money on the
your dreams my quick take on this is if
you have a job the point of it is to
learn if you are in a job where you are
learning you can a mentorship you're
making connections you get an experience
and you're getting paid to do it that's
a good reason to stay in a job if you
are in a dead-end job learning zero then
you want to look at how can you get out
really quickly I'm also not a burn the
boats kind of guy go all-in quit your
job and have no backup plan I'm much
more in the camp of start your business
on the side evenings weekends you're
hustling start making up a part-time
income and when that part-time income
can be enough that you can survive maybe
not thrive and live an amazing life but
just survive that's when I quit my job
and go full in on my business so that's
what Gary Vee thinks that's what Mel
Robbins think that's what I think I'd
love to know what do you think give me
your thoughts who do you think is right
share your perspective put it down in
the comments below
raise your standard Apple at the core is
core values
you're that evil that people with
passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's suppose
to mean and if you liked this video
check out the one we did on do you need
a college degree to be successful or not
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I think the college education is still a
great investment in yourself there's a
point of diminishing returns